MARK.
>> Mark: THAT SEEMS A BIT OF
A DESIGN FLAW, JONATHAN.
WHILE MIGRANTS CONTINUE TO
POUR INTO THE UNITED STATES.
CRITICS OF THE PRESIDENT
MAINTAIN NOTHING CAN BE DONE
BECAUSE THE WALL IS USELESS.
CNN RECENTLY RANTED ABOUT
THE FUTILITY OF MANKIND’S
OLDEST DEFENSIVE MECHANISM.
>> THIS WHOLE ISSUE IS A
CROCK FROM START TO FINISH.
HE PICKED IT UP ON THE
CAMPAIGN TRAIL AS SOMETHING
TO APPEASE THE MASSES AND
PLAY TO HIS BASE.
IT’S NOT GOING TO STOP
TERRORISM.
IT’S NOT GOING TO BE
2,000 MILES LONG AS
ORIGINALLY PLANNED.
IT’S NOT GOING TO BE
SEE-THROUGH.
IT’S NOT GOING TO BE ECHO
FRIENDLY OR FLATS OR BEADED
CURTAIN OR ANYTHING ELSE.
YOU CAN’T WALL THAT BORDER.
>> Mark: JIMMY KIMMEL
MEANWHILE HAS BEEN
RIDICULING AMERICANS SO
DESPERATE FOR A SECURE
BORDER THEY HAVE BEEN
WAITING TO DONATE TO A GO
FUND ME CAMPAIGN FOR IT.
THIS TRUMP SUPPORT ARE A GUY
NAMED BRIAN STARTED A GO
FUND ME CAMPAIGN TO RAISE A
BILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
WALL.
HE LAUNCHED IT ON SUNDAY.
IT’S ALREADY UP TO ALMOST
$9 MILLION.
THIS IS WHAT PEOPLE DO WITH
THEIR DISPOSABLE INCOME WHEN
THEY DON’T HAVE LOANS FROM
COLLEGE TO PAY OFF.
[LAUGHTER]
DONATING MONEY FOR A WALL
THAT WILL NEVER EXIST, IT’S
LIKE STARTING A COLLEGE FUND
FOR HARRY POTTER.
[LAUGHTER]
IT’S MORE USEFUL THING TO DO
WITH YOUR MONEY WOULD BE TO
GO OUTSIDE AND FEED IT TO A
BIRD.
YOU DO HAVE TO ADMIRE THE
SACRIFICE, THEY ARE MAKING.
A LOT OF THESE PEOPLE ARE
DIPPING INTO THEIR METH
MONEY FOR THIS.
>> Mark: GOT IT METH HEADS
FOR NATIONAL SECURITY.
THANK YOU, JIMMIE.
WOULD A WALL WORK OR NOT.
JASON PICCOLO IS A FORMER
SPECIAL EIGHT AND SUPERVISOR
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
HOMELAND SECURITY AND HE
JOINS US NOW.
EVERYBODY IS MORNING THIS.
WE HAVE HAD NANCY PELOSI
DOING HER BEADED CURTAIN
LINE AT THIS STAGE I WOULD
WELCOME A 2,000-MILE BEADED
CURTAIN ALONG THE SOUTHERN
BORDER IT WOULD SHOW A
CERTAIN KIND OF RESOLVE.
ARE THESE CRITICS RIGHT THAT
THIS THING DOESN’T WORK,
DOESN’T MAKE ANY DIFFERENCE,
A COMPLETE WASTE OF TIME?
>> NO.
IT WILL WORK.
THE BORDER IS 2,000 MILES
LOCK.
YOU WENT BE ABLE TO ACTUALLY
WALL THE WHOLE BORDER.
BUT THAT WILL CREATE CHOKE
POINTS OR POINTS WHERE WE
CAN ACTUALLY APPREHEND THE
IMMIGRANTS COMING.
IN YES, THE WALL WOULD WORK.
>> WHAT’S INTERESTING TO ME
IF YOU LOOK UP ON THE
NORTHERN BORDER WHERE THERE
IS FAR FEWER PEOPLE COMING
ACROSS.
NOT CARAVANS AMASSING ON THE
49TH PARALLEL.
YET THE UNITED STATES
GOVERNMENT HAS ACTUALLY PUT
PHYSICAL BARRICADES IN A LOT
OF CROSS BORDER TOWNS ON THE
CANADIAN BORDER PRESUMABLY
BECAUSE IT WORKS THERE.
SO, WHY WOULD IT NOT WORK ON
THE MEXICAN BORDER?
>> WALLS WORK.
THEY DO.
NOW, WHEN I WORKED ON THE
BORDER, THE BORDER WAS
SIMPLY A STRAND OF FENCE IN
SOME AREAS.
LIKE A STRAND OF WIRE.
NOW, YOU HAVE
NARCOTRAFFICKERS COMING
ACROSS THAT SAME AREA
MIGRANTS.
IT’S OPEN.
THE WHOLE BORDER IS PRETTY
MUCH OPEN EXCEPT FOR A FEW
MILES HERE AND THERE.
WHEN YOU SAY IT’S OPEN
BECAUSE MOST PEOPLE WHO DO
CROSS INTERNATIONAL
LEGITIMATELY LIKE THEY DO SO
BORDER POSTS.
EVEN THOUGH YOU TALK ABOUT
THAT INCESSANTLY.
THERE ARE 100-MILE STRETCHES
WHERE PEOPLE CAN JUST WALK
INTO THE UNITED STATES.
A COME WITHIN ON ORANGE
ALERT.
>> YEAH, DEFINITE LIVE.
>> I WAS ON THE SMUGGLING
CELL IN 2015 AND WE TRACKED
OF HUMAN SMUG GLIR COMING UP
FROM SOUTH AMERICA.
YOU DO HAVE THEM TRAVELING
THROUGH BRAZIL AND UP THOSE
SAME ROUTES THAT MIGRANTS
AND NARCO-TRAFFICKERS ARE
USING.
ANYONE CAN COME AND GO
THROUGH THAT BORDER.
>> Mark: YOU MEAN WHEN YOU
SAY SPECIAL INTEREST ALIENS,
YOU MEAN THAT POTENTIAL
JIHADDISTS HAVE FIGURED
OUT -- THEY LOOK AT WHAT IS
ON THEIR TV SCREENS ON THE
RIO IMRAND AND FIGURE TRYING
TO FLY TO JFK YOU MIGHT AS
WELL GO INTO’ AND WALK.
>> YOU CAN THE BORDER IS
OPEN.
I DETAILED BACK IN THE EARLY
2,000 AND IT WAS LITERALLY
ONE STRAND OF BARBED WIRE.
SO, YES, NIBBLE COULD WALK
ACROSS THAT BRTDZ WHEN
NOVEMBER FAIROUS INTEND ARE
WITH COMING HERE FOR
ECONOMIC MIGRATION.
>> A STRAND OF BAUSCH YOU
HAVE HAD WIRE SEEMS MORE